[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMEET JANI: I wanted to
introduce myself and my guest
today.
And I promise you he's going
to do the bulk of the speaking.
You don't have to listen
to a Googler drone
on for 45 minutes.
My name is Ameet Jani, and I
wanted to introduce Antoine.
I wanted to do the
introduction for one reason.
I think the French
are very modest,
and so he's not going to tell
you all of the very cool things
that Veolia is doing.
I stumbled into Veolia when
we were on an engineering trip
to France--
yes, we do have an
engineering team in France.
And this is a very
modest company
that ends up doing--
it's a 150-year-old water
company, as I describe
them, and they
are doing the most innovative
things that I've ever
seen a company do anywhere.
So I wanted to get
these guys on stage
to talk through the story.
Like many of you, they
are in multiple clouds,
and so Antoine was asking, is
it OK to show the other logo?
And so you will see the
other logo on stage,
but they run a decent cloud too.
And so Antoine's
going to focus on
how they bridge
these two worlds,
and how they use our security
solutions to really secure
the whole thing.
And so I just wanted to do
the introduction for Antoine,
because I think you're going
to hear a very great speech
today-- a talk today about
all of the cool security
things that Veolia is doing.
So I'll give it to you, Antoine.
ANTOINE CASTEX: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey.
I am Antoine Castex.
I am the Google Cloud
Product Manager at Veolia.
And as you have probably heard,
and as Ameet said, I'm French,
and so I'm from Paris.
I'm here to present you how
Veolia is moving to the Cloud,
and it can be more complex
because you will see that we
are not a small company.
And how we developed new,
modern application, and how we
helped the employees to bring--
how we bring the
employees with us
to use this modern application
and modern infrastructure.
So before talking in
detail about this,
probably most of you
don't know what is Veolia.
And as I said,
Veolia is the global
and the worldwide leader in
optimized resource management.
And I have prepared
to you a quick video
to show you what
is our daily job.
[PLAYBACK BEGINS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Let's transform a
cargo ship into chairs,
waste water into heat, and
straw into electricity.
These are new solutions
for resourcing the world.
[PLAYBACK ENDS]
ANTOINE CASTEX: So now you know
what are we doing every day,
and you also know that our
principal and main mission
is very simple--
resourcing the world.
And by resourcing
the world, we say
we want to limit the
impact on the environment
on the different businesses
we are working on.
So let's talk about
where we come from.
Probably you know that
we are very young,
because we were born in
1853, first to supply water
in Paris, France.
After, we do the same in
France, in Europe, and now
in worldwide--
sometimes in the
United States, too.
After this, we create
the energy branch,
providing solutions
for the industry.
And just after this,
we already have
to celebrate our
first centenary.
And in the last time, in 1986,
we create the last branch.
It was for the waste treatment.
And just some years
after this, a very little
and younger company you
probably know was created.
And just in the
same time, we create
the global name Veolia,
as you may know today,
regroup these three
different branches.
So today, we are 169,000
people around 50 countries,
and we are working on
these three main branches--
the water, we're supplying
water for millions of people.
The waste, by recycling millions
of tons of waste every year.
And the energy, by managing
solutions for the industry.
This is very complicated and
we have a lot of things to do.
So now let's talk
about the IT parts,
because I think this is
why you are here today.
And I choose to use
the same timeline
models to explain how
was your history on IT,
but you agree that it's
a little bit younger.
And I choose to
start to tell you
in 2012, because at this time
we were like other big company,
full-on premise.
We were having more than
200 messaging systems,
and I have choose to give
you the example of France,
where we are having more
than 10 data centers.
We have choose to
create the first biggest
program for our
employees, and this
was to migrate all
the users to G Suite.
This is a very big change,
and a very new way of work.
And just one year after
this program has begun,
we were almost 90,000
people on Gmail.
That was very crazy,
because just in one year,
we were very fast to
move the user on Gmail.
It was not easy, and I
can confirm that because I
went in the team in
charge of the migration,
but it was a very
amazing program.
I have put you some examples
about the usage we were having
at this time, because you
can at the end of this time
compare with the
information of today,
and you will see that there is
a huge evolution of the user
of the G Suite platform.
After this, we create
three main programs,
and I will speak in
details about each programs
because they are
still improving today.
And they are Move to Cloud,
Data For Business, and SATAWAD.
Just don't forget
these three names.
This is very important.
So today, we are almost
130,000 people on Gmail,
and you can compare the usage
of the G Suite platform.
Now our user uses
naturally G Suite.
This is normal.
This is not a problem.
And the problem
now is when you say
why you don't use these
services, because this
is the best way to do.
For example, the
usage of the Hangout
has a huge evolution of usage.
So about today, and to finish
this timeline, about tomorrow.
Tomorrow is in the
next two years.
And then I have
put some examples
about the big points
we want to achieve.
And they are the
migration to Chromebook--
I will speak in
detail about this
in one of the three programs.
Develop, as I say,
modern application web
apps by using Google
Cloud Services.
Be serverless and
data centerless.
It's a very huge world, and
it will have an impact for IT,
so you will understand why.
I just want to talk to you about
the cloud strategy we have.
And I have made the choice to
choose only five main points,
and I hope my
boss-- who is here--
will agree that they are
not the only one points.
But this is a very
quick presentation,
so I don't need to
speak to you more.
So I have chosen to speak to
you about these five points
because I think they
are very interesting.
First is no-ops.
And what we say with no-ops?
We say we want to let our
developers-- like me--
to focus on the cloud and not
on managing the infrastructure.
We think Google is
doing this very good.
So why we need to spend
some time on this?
We choose to use the
maximum micro-services
we can use to re-use again
and again these services.
We use Cloud Function,
we use App Engine,
we use a lot of services.
I will show you some
architectural diagram
after this.
You will see that is true.
So no-ops of course
means serverless,
because Cloud Function
is a serverless service.
And at the end, that
means no data center.
From this year, we want to
have no data center in France
in the name of Veolia,
and in the next two years
it will be the same
all over the world.
So by doing this we use
Google Cloud products.
This mean secure
by design products.
We want to seek to have
secure by design application,
and this is why we would choose
App Engine, we choose BigQuery,
we choose Cloud Function,
we choose all services
provided by Google.
And yes-- as Ameet said--
we have made the choice to
only have two different cloud
providers, they are AWS and GCP.
So I have the
authorization to put
the logo on this presentation,
so there is no problem.
Now, about the three
programs I mentioned before.
We want to create a
digital enterprise.
And create a digital
enterprise is not
as easy as speaking
to you today.
These three programs have
a lot of different detail,
and I have chosen to only record
these details in three boxes.
The first is the Move
to Cloud program.
The Move to Cloud is for the
IT entity for the branch,
and we want to help them
to move to the cloud.
For me, the biggest
keywords of this program
is software as a service
first, because we
think this is the future.
And as I said, we don't want
to manage infrastructure,
we don't want to manage.
We just want to focus on the
application and on the customer
added value we can have.
The second program
is Data For Business.
And Data For Business
for me means datalake,
because the data is the
key of your application.
And the last one is SATAWAD.
And for SATAWAD-- and I will
talk to this in detail after
this slide--
for me it's collaboration.
SATAWAD is for the employee,
and we want to, as I said,
bring them to a new, modern
on the world of application,
and new, modern ways to work.
So in detail, SATAWAD,
what does that mean?
SATAWAD means Secure, Any
Time, Anywhere, Any Device.
And it's very simple, because
as you may know in your company
today, your employee may want
to work from any time, anywhere,
and any devices.
They don't want it to
be mandatory to work
at the office.
They want to work from home.
They want to walk
from where they want.
So we propose a global
migration program to Chromebook.
We propose to give a secure
and collaborative workplace.
This is why we have chosen to
use G Suite for the messaging
system.
The second program,
Move to Cloud,
is for the IT entity, and for
the entity too, of course,
because we want them
to go to the cloud.
We are in a
decentralized company.
It means before we
were on the model
when we say, hey,
this is mandatory.
This is the new way.
You need to work like
that and not like that.
But now we are not in this way.
We are on a selective adoption.
We are on a way
where we say, hey,
you know you can make
an evolution of your IT?
You have some offer like
this, some offer like that.
We can help you.
We can make this for you.
We can give you advice.
We can give you support.
It's your choice.
And this is not the
same way to work.
And you can trust me, this is
a very more better way to work.
So this operation can
be made in two steps,
because sometimes you have a
landscape of application-- very
difficult, because
companies like Veolia
are older companies,
so they have
a big legacy of application.
So we propose a managed
services and an infrastructure
as a service solution.
But the final jump
to the cloud for us
is, as I said, the solution
as a service and the platform
as a service.
If you want you can
develop an application.
Or if you don't
want, you can buy
a solution that is ready to go.
How do we do that?
We do that in some steps.
I have chosen to [INAUDIBLE]
them in six steps.
But quickly, we help
them to discover
between what is the
application they have
and what are the
offers they can choose.
After this, we help them to
design a new architecture
of the application.
We propose to them
to help them to build
the new version of this
application, to transform
this with us or with
some Google partners,
of course, if you want.
And after this we
are going with them
to choose who will be
in charge to operate.
If this is a managed
services, that
will be maybe a cloud
provider like Google,
or that can be a
separate company.
And after all this, sometimes
we can optimize and optimize
the application for the user
experience, or for the price
and the cost of
this application.
So now you know these
two main programs.
We will speak about the last
one, this is Data for Business.
But before speaking
about the data,
I wanted to show you
how we use Google Cloud.
And today we are
almost ready to say
that we have more than 100
applications on Google Cloud.
It can be very simple
and small application
to a very big and
complex application,
and I will present
to you some demos
of applications we have made.
And this represents 500 App
Engine services, for example,
and almost 5,000
BigQuery datasets.
But the interesting point
on this is the security.
But as you can see on my
slide, we have 1,000 projects.
And 1,000 projects--
you can trust me--
is very big.
You need to secure,
you need to monitor,
you need to check
that everything
is OK on your infrastructure.
By infrastructure I mean
the Google Cloud platform,
of course.
So we have a lot of
AAN policy to do that.
We have a lot of firewalls.
We are using a lot of
different services,
and I will speak in detail
about these services
at the end of my presentation.
But now you know how
we use Google Cloud.
Let's talk about the
data, because as I said,
the data is the key.
And we think in Veolia
that having the datalake
is mandatory.
And you can see some
interesting white paper
on Google Cloud's
website on this,
and it's very close
to our approach.
And you probably asked me about
why we choose Google Cloud,
and why we create a datalake.
And I will show to you
that the datalake for us
is having a central point
of data from whatever
is there to analyze,
process, and extract
an added value of this data.
And why we chose Google Cloud?
It's very simple.
Because it's very cheap,
this is very fast,
and this is very easy to use.
So how is made, our datalake?
In just four main steps.
First, we acquire
other data, as I
said, from whatever is there--
from application,
other cloud provider--
I didn't mention any name-- from
user data, from the businesses,
or from your IoT.
I have chosen to make
just four examples,
but you can have a
very big list of data.
At this day, you can see that
we have almost 80 different data
sources around the world.
And after we have
acquired this data,
we store this without
modification and cloud storage,
because we think it's
very important to have
a history of each data we will
modify after all this step.
And as you probably
know, the storage
is very cheap
today on the cloud,
so why don't just put the
storage on cloud storage
and have this if sometimes
you need to go back,
or a modification,
at least to check.
This represents about 50
terabytes of storage today.
And after all this, we make
the most interesting point.
This is the analyze
and processing part.
We use the classic--
as I say, "classic"
pipeline data from GCB.
We use Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is
notifying dataflow.
We process dataflow
every month a lot.
You can see some numbers
of the usage we have.
And we send this
data to be queried.
This represents about
60 billion [INAUDIBLE]..
And we are very happy
to use BigQuery.
We have a big team of
experts on BigQuery,
and after this we can choose to
export this data and bring them
to external application, web
application on Google Cloud,
on-premise application--
Data Studio is an
example, if you
want to make some dashboard,
because we used it as a tool
to make some
interesting dashboard.
Where you want, because
you can open a PI
and give this data to
an external application,
as I said.
So to present you a demo
of how we use this data.
I have chosen to
present you Synoptique.
Synoptique is an external
module of the datalake.
And it will come into Veolia
to monitor all the equipment we
have on the treatment plants--
for the waste or the water,
for example.
So it means you will be able
to see, for example, how
is the amount of water I have
in my water pump today from now,
and also a very
interesting point.
This application is
made on three steps.
First is acquire the
data from the datalake,
and we get an SVG representation
of all the equipments you will
have on the treatment plants.
Second step is to prepare this.
So we merge the data of
the datalake with the SVG
representation to create
a final representation we
will present with App Engine.
After this, you can see
how this application is.
This application
is on App Engine,
and we use Angular
framework for the front end.
So Veolia's employee
can show, as I said,
in real time what are
the equipments they
have on these treatment plants.
They will be able to
choose which city they
want to monitor.
In this example, we have
some cities in France
and some cities in Germany.
But that can be very
simple or very complex.
It depends of the size
of the treatment plants
and what they are doing.
So you have a lot
of information.
They are loaded
from the datalake
every minute or second--
it depends on what you need.
And you can click
on an equipment
and have more detailed
information on what
you have on this equipment.
And as you see in my video, I
have clicked on an Information,
and I have a history
of this data.
So it's requesting
BigQuery query
to say, can you give me the
history of this information
from the last months.
You can use this data
just for your information,
or you can use an export
of this information.
So a basic front-end
application, but a very complex
back-end application.
So my second example
is not on the same web,
but it's very interesting
because it's an application--
its name is CLEAR--
which permits to monitor the
gas dispersion in the atmosphere
you have provided, and
makes by treatment plants.
And if you live near
a treatment plant,
you can be afraid if there
is not a problem today.
Maybe in the industry sometimes
you can have a problem,
and this application
is here to confirm
that there is not a problem.
Why this application
is very interesting?
Because they use
both cloud providers.
And you see that I
have made the icon.
Thank you, Ameet.
First, we collect the
data by two ways--
get the data from
the weather station,
because they can have
some wind or some rain.
And we get the data
from local sensors
all around the treatment plants.
This is on the
Veolia responsibility
to say if they want to have
10 or five local sensors.
But it depends what
you want to monitor.
After this, we store
and we simulate.
We generate the panache.
The panache is the cloud
representation of this gas
dispersion in the atmosphere.
We send this data to Google
Cloud to create with Google Map
the representation we will
display on App Engine.
As I said, we use a
lot of App Engine,
and you can see that
it's confirming.
This is the demo of
this application.
In green, you see the points are
the local sensors you can find
around the treatment plants.
You can choose different
types of sensor
and different types of gas.
And in red, you can
see in real time
the representation
of this dispersion.
This was the first
version, and now we
are on the new version
of the application
and the cloud is more beautiful.
For the first version,
it was not very,
very the most beautiful we can,
but it has evolved from now.
You can have the
version of the maps,
and you can see if your
home is at the right.
Maybe you have
recognized your street.
I don't know.
And you have a different type
of information, as I said.
It can be very
technical so that you
can have also technical
information about each sensor--
about where they are, about what
the data they have collected.
You have a historical of
this data, also taking
from BigQuery,
from the datalake.
And like Synoptic,
you can use this data
to make an export for use in
another application, of course.
These are very, very easy-to-use
applications, and not
complex to understand
how to use it.
So now it's time to speak
with Ameet about BeyondCorp,
and after I will be
back here on this.
[APPLAUSE]
AMEET JANI: Thank you, Antoine.
So the question
you're asking is,
he's created all
this great data,
he's created all these
great front ends.
How does he make sure that
the right people are accessing
this kind of information?
And so to do that I
thought I could quickly
give you a quick summary
of what BeyondCorp is.
About 10 years ago,
Google decided internally
that we wanted to
get rid of VPNs.
We decided there was this idea
that no network was really
truly safe, and in fact
the way to really guarantee
that every access--
every request-- is
actually legitimate,
to do an evaluation
of each request.
And so from that point,
we've moved all of our tools
from behind a VPN into the
world, to put it on the web.
This is including things
like our code search,
where we store our
search algorithms
and things like that.
And the idea should be that--
that's false security, and
we should make a request
on how everybody's ad
request looks at that time.
So let me walk you
through an example
of what that looks like.
In our BeyondCorp idea, we
think of really three things.
One is that you, the enterprise,
need to set policies.
These are rich
policies that say,
these are high-trust
applications.
Maybe these are cafe menus,
anybody can access it.
Those are the kinds of
rich rules you have.
And what does that mean?
What IP address
am I coming from?
What does my device look like?
What's the time of day?
These are the
types of attributes
that we want to collect when
somebody is making a request.
And then going through
and cataloging,
what are the applications
and data that we have,
and making sure
they're all protected.
And so that all those
three components
constitute what we
call BeyondCorp,
or the BeyondCorp vision.
And so let's walk through
a typical example.
There's no
revolutionary stuff here
if you look at it
at first blush.
An employee uses some sort
of device to make sure
that the rules are
processed here that say,
is this really a
legitimate request.
It's blocked at an
enforcement point,
in which case, in our case
we think of it as a proxy.
And if everything
matches, we in fact
allow that end user to access
the application or the data.
That sounds simple enough,
but a lot of things
can go wrong-- and do
go wrong-- for people
who try to go at this point.
The first one is,
how do you really
attest that this is actually
the employee who's trying
to access the information.
Right?
In terms of phished
credentials, if you
think of their entire effect,
the number one attack vector
used to access information.
It's very easy to mimic
who an employee is.
Second, even if the user is
legitimate, what is the device?
Is the device in a
compromised state?
Is it a corporate device?
You know, is it a tablet?
What is it that's
going on there?
The next thing you
have to figure out
is, how do I make sure
that the rules I've
applied against my
applications are legitimate?
Are they over-privileged?
Is the network path vulnerable?
And then you have to collect
all this information together
and see, should an access
decision be made or not,
before the access decision
is actually allowed.
And in each of these, we
do this on every request
to an application,
so the latency
has to be near zero in order
to not frustrate your customer,
right?
You're replacing a VPN, but
if you're putting something
in that's much
heavier, you in fact
create more headaches
for your end users.
And so what we've decided
to do is attack each
of these verticals with
multiple solutions.
The first one is, you need
to have a strong identity
provider.
And this is not an
identity provider talk,
so I'm not going
to dive into that.
But we need to attest that
this is in fact a strong user.
But we want to go one
step further, right?
If you talk about second
factor, most second factors
are actually phishable
credentials, right,
or bare tokens.
And so we need to have
a phishing-resistant
authentication that we use.
And we at Google use the
touch key, the U2F keys.
The next thing is on the
device itself, right?
If it's a mobile device, we
want strong MDM on the device.
If it's a laptop, we need
to ensure that the device is
actually in a good state.
And you can do that in
several different ways,
and we can talk to those.
The first one is around
device management.
You need to make sure that we
have a well-configured TLS us
when you make the request.
That's an obvious attack vector.
You have to have a
very simple rules
engine when you do all of this.
When you put all
of this together,
it needs to be very
clear to an admin
or to a [INAUDIBLE] person.
Am I building the right thing?
Am I doing the right thing?
Are these applied correctly
against the application?
And then of course
we have the proxy,
where the access
controls happen,
and then of course
we terminate the TLS.
And assuming everything
is right there,
then of course we allow
access to the applications.
That could be applications,
it can be data.
But think about this
new cloud world.
No matter what cloud you use,
one of the biggest attack
vectors that are out there--
these are public APIs, right?
If you want to write
to a storage bucket
that is a public API.
And so you need to be able
to extend your security
boundary around those APIs.
And so we have solutions
that we're introducing
around that space too.
And so I thought maybe it makes
sense to talk to these briefly
before I give it
back to Antoine.
But the first one
that we did at Google
was to introduce this idea of
an identity database, right?
It has to have a
rich set of metadata,
which includes the users,
the group memberships, job
titles, offices, where is
somebody coming in from.
That's all par for
course, I think.
The next thing you
need to have is,
you need to have
strong authentication.
These are primary credentials,
but these are also
secondary credentials.
Think of the U2F keys
and things like that
so that you can actually test
that this is the right user.
And they need to have
short-lived sessions.
A lot of these
vendors today have
sessions that go on forever.
If you're accessing
something that's
a business-critical
value, clearly it makes
sense that you need to have
very short-lived sessions,
versus if you're accessing,
again, the cafe menu.
Those sessions can live forever.
The other thing that
we've introduced just
in the last week is something
we call endpoint verification.
Endpoint verification is this
idea that on your device itself
we can take a look at the
security posture of the device.
Is this the user's
right serial number?
Is the OS version up to date?
Is the screen lock enabled?
Is there disc encryption?
On and on and on, you can
capture simple metrics
about the end user's
device to say, yes,
this is a safe device.
This is not a safe device.
This is a corporate device.
This is not a device--
before you allow access
to applications.
And then, of course,
you need a proxy.
We at Google have
something called
the Identity-Aware Proxy.
The Identity-Aware
Proxy in essence
is a large, global
scale reverse proxy
that sits in front of all
of our infrastructure.
And what it does
is it intercepts
all of the requests that
are going to an application
and makes a check.
We said this was Ameet's device.
It's a corporate device
for him, and he's
coming in from an
IP address that I
trust, let's allow access.
Or most of these
things are true,
but he's coming from
a public coffee shop.
Maybe we should upgrade and
ask for a second factor here,
right?
And so those are the
kinds of decisions
you could start to make
at the proxy layer.
And then of course, how do
you bring this all together?
You need to have what we call
an access control engine.
This is where you can start to
define simple rules that say,
I've classified all
of the applications
into really, really secure,
OK to leak information,
and not secure at all.
I need to define what
those mean, right?
I need to understand
that, if I'm
coming in for a really,
really secure application,
it needs to come in from
a trusted IP address.
I can set that.
I can say that, in
fact, I need to know
that it's a Chromebook,
because I trust Chromebooks
more than I trust others--
in our case-- so I want to
grant access to that device
more than I would, for example,
a Mac or a Windows device.
And you can start
to see how you would
be able to create these rules.
You have thousands and
thousands and thousands
of internal applications.
All right, well at
least we at Google do,
and I'm sure many of you have
the same order of magnitude.
You need to be able to find
a scalable way of applying
all of these rules against
those applications.
If you have to go through
and do a one by one by one
kind of application
of those rules,
you'll never get through it,
and you'll never actually
fully roll out the model.
And so what we actually have
done with our own access
control engine that we're
now product testing for users
is create these ideas of
simple access levels, right?
To classify something is
sensitive, to access it,
I need to be coming in
from a specific IP address,
or I need to come in from a
specific version of an OS.
If something is mostly trusted,
OK, it's coming in from me.
All right, that's good enough.
And it's coming in from
a mostly up-to-date OS.
I'll allow that access to
what we call mostly trusted.
Or if it's an end user's tablet
that they brought from home
and they want to access
that data, that's OK too.
They can only access a
certain tier of applications.
So I wanted to walk
through an actual example
of what we do at
Google, and what
we're exposing to end users.
So let's take this user.
This is Joe.
He's sitting in his office.
He's using his Mac.
We know the serial number, we
know the status of the device.
The rules check out.
It's a corporate device,
he's the right person,
so he can in fact
access our bug system.
So identity-- or proxy, in our
case-- for this global proxy
will make that
evaluation and say,
yep, he should have access
to business critical systems
here where he can see
those kinds of things.
Now let's take a sort corollary.
This will seem obvious, but
there's resolutions here
that we should talk about.
Again, this is Joe, but
now Joe's using his tablet.
And so the rules in general
say, well, this is Joe, yes.
It's Joe's tablet, I know
nothing about this device,
and it's coming in from
a public IP address.
I can't allow access
to that system, right?
And so in this case, the proxy
will say, no, deny the access.
That's an obvious
kind of workflow
that we're talking about here.
But let's talk about some
of the details, here.
You can start to make
this a richer use case,
here, where you can
say maybe this is Joe,
maybe this is Joe's
tablet and it's
coming in from a
public IP address,
but he still needs
to do his job.
He still needs to be
able to access systems--
maybe not the bug tracking
system, but definitely
his calendaring
system, and definitely
his email system-- whatever--
definitely his HR systems,
so he can take the time
off if he needs to.
But you can start to
come back and set rules
that say, OK, this is
Joe and Joe's tablet,
and I don't know much
about Joe's tablet,
but if he presents a
legitimate second factor
then we can in fact allow
him access to what we call
middle-tier applications like
calendaring and other kinds
of systems.
That's how we at Google resolve
these kinds of problems.
And these are the kinds
of systems that we're now
exposing with our Identity-Aware
Proxy and other set of tools
for customers to use.
So I'll give it back to
Antoine to talk about how
Veolia uses those things.
ANTOINE CASTEX: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Ameet.
It was very funny because
when we are providing
this presentation, we made
the slide on each side,
and when are
discussing Ameet said,
hey, you have almost
the same slides as me.
So we say, we have the same
problem and the same security
concerns.
These are on four points.
First is the identity
of your user.
Are they the person
they pretend to be?
You need to be sure that the
device is not compromised,
and you need to be sure
the data transport is good.
And of course, the
application, if this
is well protected or not.
So how BeyondCorp--
and thank you again,
Ameet, and all the
BeyondCorp teams for the help
you provide to Veolia.
How BeyondCorp
helps us every day?
I have chosen to resume a very
quick list of the services
we use every day to secure and
monitor our GCP infrastructure.
First, near the Veolia logo
is the cloud security command
center.
This is a very
new service, and I
recommend you to
test it because it
will be very helpful to
have on every central point
all the external
services of security
you can choose to have,
and inventory of all
the objects you have on GCP.
On the first line
you see BeyondCorp,
because BeyondCorp is
also a team which is
making some great white papers.
You can read them.
They are very interesting.
You have also the cloud resource
manager with the folder,
the custom rules--
the AAM rules.
And you have a big
and a lot of work
to do if you want to be
the most effective company.
On the second line you
have the GCP billing,
because by the
billing, we think we
can monitor if the usages of
the platform are good or not.
We can detect some fraud.
Maybe if on Monday
morning, I see
people which are using
a lot of BigQuery,
maybe this is normal because
we have special workers,
or maybe this is not normal if
the people don't know the best
way to request BigQuery.
So the billing is the
key to monitor this.
Second is the VPC.
VPC service control
is the new service
which permits you to
secure and separate
some different
services of a project,
and lets communicate just the
two BigQuery services of two
different projects.
You have a lot of different
ways to use these services,
but it's very interesting
and very important.
On the third line,
you have cloud AAP.
And if you have seen on my two
applications on the diagram,
we use AAP on every app
engine services we create.
Security scanner, which
is related to app engine.
It permits you to
scan your application
and check if you have some
vulnerability on your code.
And after this,
on the third line
you have more the user
and employees part,
with the security key
enforcement with the two steps.
The Chromebook migration,
because migrate to a Chromebook
is a little bit more
secure than a laptop.
I will not mention a
certain operating system.
The key management services
for the application
to store and secure your key.
And on the last two
points, they are for me
the two most interesting,
because in my job
I use them every day.
The first is Security Monkey.
Security Monkey is an
open-source product provided
by Netflix, and it permits you
to monitor your infrastructure
from AWS and GCP on
just the same dashboard.
So it's very
helpful if you don't
want to have two
different solutions.
And the last one is ForCity.
And yesterday I was
with the ForCity team,
and I recommend you to
test this because it's
a new security open-source
project sponsored by Google.
It's permits you to
have an inventory
of all the objects you have.
It permits you to
detect some violation
you have on your infrastructure,
and to enforce some policy.
Maybe, for example,
if I think that I
have port 25 open
on any instance
I have on compute
engine is a problem,
I say, when you detect
this port is open, just
quickly direct this false, so
you don't care about the rest.
So now you know the
different services we use.
We have a new project
and we are working today
with BeyondCorp teams on this.
They are coming in Paris
to understand what we need,
and we are improving
today and still tomorrow
on these parts,
because now we want
to open our application
to our customers.
But you know, it's very
complicated and not
easy to create an identity.
On G Suite, for
example, if you want
to let authenticate
your customers,
sometimes you don't want to
have to monitor this user,
and of course you
don't want to pay
a license for a
user which will be
connecting on your application.
So what's your ID?
Your ID is very simple, and I
have made a very interesting
example.
Imagine a case where Veolia
is in charge of the water
treatment of Los Angeles.
I am the mayor of
the city, and you
agree that I have a
very good promotion.
So Veolia gives me the URL
of the application Clear
that I have presented
to you before.
So I need to connect
on this application
to check if everything
is OK in Los Angeles.
I'm connecting to the URL.
AAP says, stop, I'm here
to check who you are.
They bring me to a portal,
a very simple page developed
by Veolia, where I just need to
say if I'm an internal people,
or if I'm customers.
On this example, I will
say I'm a customer.
And I'm redirecting
to an IdP provider.
On this example, I
have chosen one login,
but you can use a different
type and list of IdP provider.
This IdP provider checked if
I'm existing on this database,
and if yes--
and that's the most interesting
part of this example--
I'm connecting to this new
product of Google Cloud.
This name is Cloud Identity
for Customers and Partners.
maybe it will not
the final name,
but I am not here to
make an announcement.
But don't forget to follow this
very interesting, new product.
And this product
is here for what?
It's here to say, my IdP
say, OK you are present.
And now I am connecting
to the cloud identity
domain of the
customers of Veolia
to create an identity which
will be connecting the IdP
provider to this domain.
And now, OK, you
have the permission
to go to this application.
AAP say, OK, I give
you this application.
If I was click on A, I'm
internal people of Veolia,
I think you probably
know what will happen.
I will redirect to my
G Suite Veolia domain,
and I will instantly
connect to this application.
Don't forget the Cloud Identity
Customers and Partners.
And I will again say
thank you to the team who
is in charge of this.
And I know some people of
this team are here today.
And thank you, Ameet, for this.
So my last slide is
more a funny slide.
I recommend you to connect
with all the device you
have on this URL,
ResourcingMachine.Veolia.com,
now or tomorrow.
You can be a
resourcer too, and you
can see what type of different
application we can develop.
And this is a game to permit
you to be a resourcer.
It's on App Engine,
also, of course.
So what's the future now?
The future, as I said,
is open new applications
to the customer and develop
more and more secure
applications on Google Cloud.
Thank you.
Merci.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]